شهران ونصف تفصل تركيا عن استحقاق هو
الاهم منذ عقود انتخابات الرئاسيه
وبرلمانيه سترسم معها مستقبل البلاد
ومستقبل رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس الذي تصدر
المشهد منذ عقدين في خضام استعدادات
الجميع للحدث الابرز جاءت كارثه الزلزال
المدمر لتلقي بظلالها على الاستحقاق
الانتخابي وعلى الاطراف السياسيه الفاعله
في البلاد ولا شك على حزب العداله
والتنميه ورئيسه
هناك العديد من الاستبيانات التي قالت ان
شعبيه الحزب الحاكم تراجعت بنسبه 13% خلال
العام رغم الجهود التي بذنوها كزياده الحد
الادنى للاجور وتخفيض سن التقاعد لكن بعد
زلزال باتت الحكومه في وضع اصعب من الوضع
الذي كانت عليه
الشركات ابحاث عديده
تقاريرها عن نسبه تاييد الناخبين للاحزاب
السياسيه في تركيا لا شك ان بعض هذه
التقارير اشارت الى تراجع طفيف في شعبيه
الحزب الحاكم وبعضها الاخر اشار الى
ارتفاع طفيف في نسبه تاييد الحزب بالشارع
لكن تقريبا كل التقارير والدراسات ما زالت
تعطي اردوغان افضليه على منافسيه
يوجد خوف لدى الحكومه وهذا واضح خوف من
فكره ان يؤثر الزلزال على الانتخابات لذلك
هناك محاولات مثلا لتامين البيوت يحاولون
تغيير هذه الظروف السلبيه وهذا يجب ان
يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار لكن بالعموم لا شك ان
الزلزال اثر سلبا على الحكومه التوقعات
بعد الزلزال
ذهبت الى ان حكومه اردوغان ستدفع ثمن
تقصيرها في التعاطي مع ازمه الزلزال
الى الساعات والايام الاولى بصناديق
الاقتراع لكن رياح السياسه في معسكر
المعارضه هبت بما يشتهيه اردوغان ويتمناه
ميرال اكشنر زعيمه حزب الخير تنقلب على
تحالف الطاوله السداسيه في سيناريو يبعد
المعارضه بشكل اني عن احتمالات الفوز لكن
احتمالات تماسك من بقي في هذا التحالف ما
زالت قائمه والمشهد قد يتغير بين لحظه
واخرى هزات الزلزال في جنوب تركيا انتقل
صداها الى العاصمه انقره وخيمت على المشهد
السياسي ويبدو انها ستلقي بظلالها الثقيله
على اردوغان وحسبه الا اذا غرقت المعارضه
اكثر في خلافاتها ولم تستطع تجاوز ازمتها
الراهنه زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول